What are the best probiotics for someone with reoccurring vaginal tract infections, UTI infections, one of the best probiotics?
Well, I always suggest that you alternate probiotics.
I know there's more and more science coming out about specific probiotics for specific issues and specific biomes of your body, microbiomes of your body.
However, I think it's best to alternate probiotics. I also think that you're not going to cure your problem by taking probiotics.
So, it's not so much a probiotic deficiency, meaning I need to take one type of probiotic short of solving my problem.
One of the probiotics that you get in a capsule of probiotics compared to what you get in your food in a variety of different foods is not even comparable.
It's really more so what you're eating. If I'm getting chronic recurrent UTIs, you need to dig a little deeper to figure out the why.
So there can be different triggers, different food sensitivities, different chemical sensitivities that are causing these things.
So you need to dig to why. While this is a good and valid question, I don't want to mislead somebody that you're just like one supplement away or one probiotic away from solving my problem.
You got to dig to why it's there in the first place.
I just saw an article really interesting that came out about these tighter slacks that gals are wearing more today, these yoga type things.
They did a study and they found the chemical that was in them is such a high concentration of hormone disruption chemical.
So this is right here your imaginal track that you're wearing these tight pants and then you could think, well, that makes me think about underwear that makes me think about other things that I'm putting on my body, creams, lotions, all this kind of stuff has chemicals in it.
That is hormone, not only hormone disruptor, what is that going to my body? What is that causated and mutory action in my body? Major issues. Those are the things that you want to dig in with recurrent infections of any kind.